let's go next to our caller from the
four seven zero area code four seven
zero go ahead hey I'm Martin from the
Stone Mountain Georgia just a
hypothetical situation here so say if
there was an independent independent
candidate running for president right
and they hired you as their campaign
manager what two or three key points
would you hammer home in order for that
candidate to become like a viable option
for president United States to compete
with the machines of the Democrat uh I
mean listen I couldn't tell you what
would make them the most viable I know I
would like to see them focus on a a
socially driven economy getting money
out of politics and the environment
right though I mean if you're saying
pick three things that I believe are the
sort of overarching issues that we need
to deal with it in our society it would
be those three will that make them
viable third party presidential
candidates probably not I mean the
depressing thing is there probably isn't
a list of three things I can come up
with because the system is deliberately
designed not to allow exactly what
you're suggesting which would be a great
thing well the reason why just limit it
to just three is because I just feel
like I mean there's definitely more than
three you know just for the sake of time
and I feel like you know just I guess
keep things brief yeah those I mean
those really nice three the thing is I
don't know you know if if the question
is just what would make them the most
viable you just just run polls right run
polls and figure out what three issues
can you get majority agreement on and
concoct a candidate that that would have
those the thing is it's so much about
personality and it's so much about
funding and it's so much about the
Democratic and Republican parties that
you still probably wouldn't even do that
well even if you poll-tested the three
least controversial positions where you
come up with say these are my three
things and 78% of the country agrees
with me running as a third party
candidate the deck is stacked against
you and you probably still are not going
to do that well unfortunately and that's
why the system itself is what needs to
be changed it's it's unfortunately
bigger than a candidate picking three
positions or four or whatever number
yeah it just seems like
a shame because it just seems like we're
kind of just kicking the can you know
just one side Republican one side
Democrat yep and I feel like just some
time in Europe like you know they have
parties sprouting up you know from
grassroots then you know they they have
a little bit more variety per se as far
as like the spectrum in regards to the
candidate that they pick where a hundred
percentages 100 percent agree with you
think yeah thank you things like no no
no way for independent candidate and
I've done a bunch of videos about how
how the third-party candidates can break
in it's depressing I appreciate you
calling though thank you so much